hey thanks so much for coming down to my
house hey my pleasure i
just love to see people winning and the
fact that you've got so many different
property developments going on
you've done well bro yeah um
it's been a journey it's been a long
time but yeah uh thanks to
in part to a lot of your training and a
lot of your videos that i've uh
pretty much consumed most of them if not
all of them on youtube
that's so good it's been a great help
that's i really appreciate that and you
know what i know there's nothing in it
for you being here
apart from to inspire people to
encourage people absolutely and that's
why i run my whole channel
so why don't you just talk me through a
little bit about how you get started in
property because i know
i know you've done a bit of training and
it's helped you scale it but you've been
in property for how long
yeah i bought my first property in 1996
the year that i got married
so i would have been a kid at school
right then little kid at school little
kid at school maybe so
taught me through the journey and the
reason i did it is because my older
brother
john uh he bought a house in lewisham 60
thousand pound
two bed two reception he lived in one
rented out the other three rooms
was making uh loads of money and within
a few years he sold it for
300 grand nice and so and today that
property is probably worth 700 000
yeah and so within a short period of
time
i bought my first property in lewisham
as well bought it for 60 grand and i
sold it two years later for 112
and a half thousand pound nice so i made
50 grand for doing nothing
yeah and i rented it out we didn't call
it hmos back then but it was a hm it was
a room by room
yeah it was very much they had to sort
out the bills amongst themselves back
then
you know just read that room and
whatever they did they shared it amongst
themselves
and so that covered the cost of the
mortgage put money in my pocket on top
plus you know uh 50 60 grand
profit in about two three years and you
know what though when you buy
at the right time you can that can
happen absolutely
now i wouldn't say it's harder but but
we can't i don't think you can rely on
capital appreciation which is why i'm a
massive advocate for hmos
talk to me about kind of what you've
achieved um since then
i know you've scaled when did you come
to the crash course
so i came to a crash course probably
about two years ago probably about 2018
i reckon
so what had happened because i'm a
pastor and i went into ministry and i
was heavily involved in ministry i was
doing 80 hours a week
pastoring every day and actually for a
few years i was working a job in the
city of london
i worked for a merchant bank and so i
was working full-time as a merchant
working for a merchant bank and i was
pastoring full-time
and running the family and so my initial
rentals were just single that's after
that first initial
uh room by room basis when i got into
the ministry i thought well
i'll just do single that's easier you
know it's less time i haven't got too
much time
to be uh managing those properties so
i'd rent out to a family
wouldn't make much per month maybe a
couple of hundred pounds a month yeah
but there was a great capital
appreciation
over the long term so i had several of
those and then when i came to your
course i'd already had in my mind the
idea of doing hmos
so i come to your course and i'm just
sitting there and i'm listening to what
you're talking about hmos and the
and it was a no-brainer yeah it made
complete
i was there hitting myself in your why
didn't i do this years ago
and in addition to that what had
happened is that one of my properties
uh we'd led it to three guys
on a single tenancy they'd come in
together three of them
were on one contract and what they did
they brought in
two of their friends and they were all
living in rooms and so they were hmo
amongst themselves internally in your
house in my house
and so i was like even these guys have
got enough sense i wasn't bothered by
that yeah i paid their rent on time
uh so that was actually my first hmo and
i said to them at the end of the tenancy
guys
i'm gonna transition to renting out the
rooms well they all stayed
yeah and they decided to pay me 500
pounds each
uh i think on that one i was getting
four 1400 pounds
a month rent and that went to two and a
half thousand pound
or two thousand six actually because
they were all paying 500 and above
and so they were doing the hmo amongst
themselves
on a single let yes and so as soon as i
said
actually i'm gonna make this official
yeah they all said well we're gonna stay
we'll just pay
that's just the smallest little change
though absolutely being aware
of something like oh you can absolutely
instantly bang when we met at the crash
course i hope you don't mind me asking
what kind of money were you making in
property when we met when we first met
there was a big
uh i was probably across my the
portfolio i'm thinking i
i know i had several properties i was
probably making
a thousand yeah maybe two thousand
pounds no
i crossed a lot of them though total
yeah that wasn't that huge no no but to
a lot of people i mean it's a lot better
than most people
yeah i know but for having several
properties it was only a few hundred
pounds
in london yeah it's not a huge and you'd
got to that point
you're making a thousand to two thousand
yeah you've got to that point by what
just like working hard saving money
buying houses delayed gratification
great so you had all the discipline
you had all the money management all
that stuff
absolutely but then 2018 you switched up
the strategy a little bit yeah how much
are you making right now today
a profit per month across the board in
property property alone i'll say it's
gonna be at least 10
11 12 000. that's amazing yeah that's
amazing
simply by changing that strategy and
also what i do i use the brr strategy as
well
i buy properties um that typically need
a
light refurb as light as possible yeah
sometimes it doesn't work out that way
and i force up the value and refinance
so i've done three this year yeah
i probably done two or three last year
and uh yeah i'm constantly doing them
and i'll probably do maybe one or two
before the year finishes
so what i want to know now is i want to
know the secrets
the nuggets the wisdom because it's so
funny because
everyone's got their own story their own
version their own so i might do
something and teach something and say
something one way
you might adapt you do the same thing
but it communicated in a totally
different way
which reaches more people so what have
been the the biggest kind of lessons if
you were sort of
advising someone in property say you're
talking to someone who's got a couple
houses they want to scale
your hmos would you be honest what would
the best piece of advice you give to
them
well i think it starts off with
education that's without you know you
don't know what you don't know yeah
so uh i'm hoping to start some
development work
and one of the first people i called was
a guy who i know he's currently right
now
uh shout out to evan uh who's building
his own house he's building the house so
yeah i called him up
i've got a ton of questions he's sending
me spreadsheets he sent me information
and it's interesting a two-hour
conversation with him or an hour
conversation with him
has informed me enough to make me more
confident
yeah in this deal that i'm about to try
and acquire
and so you just don't know what you
don't know yeah
and there's a lot of um there's a lot of
fear around investing in property
because if you get it wrong
it's a lot of money to get wrong yeah
but i think that fear is mitigated
by knowledge love that if you know what
you're doing if you're confident
i mean the fact that it took me several
years to transition from single lets to
multi-lets
yeah i mean seriously i mean the amount
of due diligence i would do before
getting the property i would spend
weeks trying to figure out trying to do
the figures do all the comparables
you know does the figures stack up um
one of the properties i bought
this year i didn't even see the property
i got to the auction late because i was
after another property
was frustrated because i had all of this
work done for this property flicked
through the catalogue saw something
did some due diligence there in the
auction hall
um online etc etc and i bought it
yeah and that at the moment is giving me
40 return
investments incredible and so it took me
years
to transition from single lets to
multi-lets
but once i had that knowledge and done
my first
one or two multilet it became yeah water
for ducks back
yeah and i love that and so that
knowledge certainly is the key thing the
second thing i would say
yeah is take an action yeah yeah a lot a
lot of people especially in my world
a lot of people talk and we talk a lot
about
yeah we're going to do this one day do
that one day and you know those days
pass and you've been saying the same
thing for the last couple of years so
yeah certainly education taking action
yeah would be two of the critical things
if you're gonna make it in property i
love that bro
i would say knowledge action belief
and persistence yeah absolutely there
you go yeah that's the ingredients to
the cake
of success absolutely let me ask you a
question are entrepreneurs
born or made uh are they born or made
i'd say they're more made than born
okay i think it's more nurtured in
nature however some people are
by nature entrepreneurs i actually think
it's your world it's your environment
yeah uh some people are you know uh my
i'm nigerian my parents are nigerian
nigerians are by
nurture entrepreneurs might not always
be the best ones but they've certainly
got an entrepreneurial spirit about them
and so some cultures entrepreneurship is
just a way of surviving
yeah if you're not an entrepreneur
because there's no welfare system
there's no government assistance there's
no there's no welfare houses no council
housing
so if you don't work out how to turn the
pound into two pounds
you're going to be stuck yeah and so i
think there's a lot of nurturing
that comes through it so i believe
anyone can be an entrepreneur
if they can get there if they can
acquire the mindset of an entrepreneur
and so if you come from a very affluent
background where everything's done for
you you've never had to work for money
etc etc you can still become
entrepreneurial but something's got to
change in your mind
as opposed to someone who's like hey
i've got to hustle today
because if i don't work i'm not going to
eat yeah i mean when you're under that
sort of pressure when you're
if you have to go out your house first
thing in the morning to look for money
to feed your family that day you have
the energy for entrepreneurship
yeah and you just need to ally that
energy with education
the right environment where you can yeah
you know be successful
so interesting you said because most of
my friends and even students and myself
who are entrepreneurial
making very good money actually started
with very little yeah and had to really
hustle hard
so now when i see people i was just
chatting you just met him to a pizza guy
yeah
he literally stopped me in the street
you know and now he's around the house
we're doing deals
but it's like yeah i was raised in the
council house right
have you asked about your background
yeah i was raised a single parent my mom
died when i was young
so i was raised by my dad and we've got
four brothers um
and so he's raising a very masculine
alpha male but
poor environment and it's very
interesting as i look at all of my
brothers how we've all turned out
none of us are poor today yeah and i
think it has to do with our upbringing
that's why i mentioned it's nurturing
sometimes
when you come from an environment where
you didn't have anything
you certainly learn just by me and even
then when you get something you're
always very aware of what it's like not
to have anything yeah
so this is the other thing about risk is
that um sometimes when you come from a
poor background when you get something
you like to hang on to it
right you don't want to release it so
easy because if you screw this up
you only go back to where you've gone so
something has to shift in your mind
that you've got the knowledge you've got
the skills like you said the belief
uh that even if you were to lose you
would get it back again yeah
however i've never lost them properly
ever ever
ever ever never ever yeah you know why
though because pro
not only are you educated and you've had
to learn and you've done training and
different things
but also property is a pretty safe
investment
you know if i knew back then what i knew
now
my property portfolio probably worth 100
million yeah
i mean it's crazy i mean um they say
property prices double every 10 years
i disagree with that i think in london
it's every five to six years
it can be yeah i mean like i said i
bought a property 60
000 sold it three years later for 112
000. i sold it in 1999.
the guy who i sold it to sold it in
2015.
i checked it online and i think he sold
it for half a million
i mean that's ridiculous it is
ridiculous because you know what's
really interesting four or five of those
yeah yeah yeah but in 2009 2010
everyone was saying it's terrible time
it's terrible time yeah from 2009 2010
to 2015-16 properties did double that's
right
right right in the brink of it
absolutely i mean that's working canary
wolf
yeah canary wharf is typically a very
under
deprived area very poor you know
rundown area and i can remember when i
worked in canary wharf my supervisor
buying the flat
for a hundred and fifty thousand pounds
yeah and i remember mocking them saying
that oh you got ripped off there's no
way enough that flat's worth for 150
000.
it's a million today wow interesting
it's interesting
in 20 years you know what though whilst
i do agree with you completely
the the way i teach and you know this
because you've done some training is
very much around cash flow
because i think i think cash flow is
king because capital appreciation is
nice but it does not pay the bills
it's nice when it happens but you can't
bank on it um
so cash flow you you know you've got 10
11 12 000
profit coming in cash flow per month
what kind of
um like what kind of advice would you
give to somebody around trying to
maximize their cash flow going from a
going from someone that's a single
letter investor to a multi investor what
were some of the challenges some of the
lessons
in in making that transition and up in
that cash flow it was real easy
just do it i mean i remember you i
remember you saying one time on your
videos
you turn a front room into a bedroom
by putting a bed in it
yeah it's just like yeah that's too easy
yeah
i'm saying it's really it's too easy
it's as simple as that yeah and i've had
people ask me well
what you got to do to the rooms i said
listen you've got to put a bed in there
right and they're like okay go on
i said that's it it's a bedroom yeah
yeah so true and so
uh multi-let's is actually very little
difference and i was very nervous
it's going to take me more time it's
going to if i spend
maybe two three hours a week yeah
on my portfolio that's a busy week
right you know someone's broke something
someone's broke a washing machine or
someone's yeah you know they've done
something and i've had to
get involved and same story with my
portfolio i got management systems all
set up but then but then i've got an
overseer
who manages the managers so for me it's
five minutes a month yeah and people
and people think i'm joking it's like no
it's five minutes a month on the
management
people think i'm joking when i say put a
bed in it people think i'm you know i
remember
i remember saying actually even i know
we were talking about before it was even
um
channel four right that took a little
clip of me a crash course
saying the asking price the i was saying
the difference between the asking price
and the market value yeah like the
asking price is what they're asking
that's right the market value is a
different thing that's right and they
were like
oh it's so obvious it's so basic it's
like no that's right that's right
it's really important absolutely
sometimes we'll think i've got it 20
below market value you go 20 below
market absolute price that's right
absolutely very different thing
if these little things which can make a
massive difference but actually they're
very simple yeah and value is know the
difference
yeah values don't care when you try and
refinance on the property
they don't really care what you're
trying to ask for it yeah they will go
through and say well no this is the
market value yeah
so yeah if anyone's got you're right
cash flow is king
there's no two ways about it and if
anyone has single that's they're trying
to transition
into multilet they just need to get them
done as quickly as possible yeah
especially as there's a lot of article
four coming in and yeah shiny permission
etc etc
yeah and so um yeah and it's a
no-brainer and actually for me it's been
actually safer because i did a single
that one time
where the tenant didn't pay the bill
yeah and it's very interesting i've
never had
a hmo tenant not pay their bills
and it's something about you know and
even if they did at least you've got
other
income streams coming in from that
property yeah when you do a single let
and they don't pay their rent
that's it you're not getting anything
from that property correct whilst
they're not
paying their rent yeah well if you've
got five people then one doesn't pay
at least you've got four income streams
coming yes and one's been clogged up
but generally speaking people that rent
rooms in my experience
tend to pay their bills yeah tend to pay
the rent and if you have a single let
you can't even go into the property no
you can't you can't have been going to
your own house
yeah you know if they say we don't want
to come to the property you can't but
are they multi
legally you can you can't go into their
rooms but you can be around the building
doing maintenance doing checks etc etc
what kind of areas are you investing in
around
london croydon south london croydon all
of my properties are within the 10
15 minute drive for my house what kind
of demographic tenants
do you have working professionals okay
so oftentimes if i go to the house no
one's in
yeah they're all at work you ever have
students
um once or twice graduates they're right
masters and stuff that's right
absolutely not these 18 year olds
no no that's two yeah well 16 year olds
so one guy wanted to rent my place
and his dad was going to be guarantor
for it but right it hasn't worked out
yet
yeah yeah because i think he's too young
what about what about lha
benefit tenants nah i'm not messing with
none of that stuff
you know what though it's good i worry
about i have people who worry about
their credit score
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
people who work a job they've got
regular income
coming in and what i offer them is very
nice newly refurbished
clean modern accommodation at the
cheapest price
yeah very rarely are you going to be
able to rent something as nice as this
cheaper than what i'm offering yeah i'm
saying do you know what's good though
um you know your market yeah you know
your product yeah and that's called
business
absolutely so so it's not discriminating
it's not but people say this stuff well
i i read the blog
where some government minister was
saying you shouldn't be asking people
yeah that they should or you shouldn't
be no dss they banned it from the advert
yeah that's right
you can't say no dss you can't say you
must be working full time etc etc
but that's actually nonsense because
actually if you do landlords insurance
one of the questions they're going to
ask you is what type of tenants
are you having in your property yeah and
guess what they asked you are they dss
are they working full-time are they
students yeah exactly so the legal
system
yeah says we want to know what type of
tenants
but somehow we can't ask the question
exactly
and if you try to do a buy to let
mortgage
for dss i don't think you'll get it no
if you said to them oh i'm just gonna
focus on this particular market i think
they might be a bit nervous about that
yeah yeah
so what what's the and you're a pastor
how did you come to christ uh i became a
christian in 1994.
uh i was a typical red-blooded young
dude
i was attending north london university
went into the library
my friend uh dorae was talking to two
girls i said well he's got two girls
he can talk to one i'll talk to the
other i started talking to the other
girl
and within 10-15 minutes she said you
need to come to church with us you need
jesus
and i was like okay we ended up going to
a church
i got saved that night gave my life to
christ in wolfensteil
east london in 1994. okay
and then uh yeah it's been awesome since
then and you've got such a massive heart
to
inspire absolutely you know talk to me a
bit about that because i mean there's
parts of coin
that ain't that nice right yeah there's
some rough parts yeah i mean
there's also some very nice parts yeah
okay like everywhere like everywhere
everyone's got it's good i mean we're
right now in a nice part of beckonsfield
but yeah but there's there's still parts
where there's council houses and stuff
it's always the case um what's your
what's your reason why are you doing
this why are you improvising well i
think uh well number one's for me and my
family
yeah you know i'm gonna leave a legacy
for my kids i'm gonna leave inheritance
my children's children i'm also a
grandfather
so i'm thinking two generations or more
down the road
and so and also because i grew up poor
and i know it's like to be poor
i know it's like to be poor and i know
it's like not to be poor
i really do prefer not being poor yeah
all right there's a big difference
but also so much of our problems in our
community
are economic problems you know we've got
um parents who are working two free jobs
china
trying to make ends meet you know um the
kids come from poor backgrounds
typically
uh tend to get into trouble and so it's
about empowering people with the
knowledge
where they can be financially free and
they they can make
choices mine doesn't make you happy but
money does allow you to make choices
that can um take away some pressures
yeah which can give you a sense of
happiness sure
you know that's what people don't
understand and so um and i think in this
country
uh poverty shouldn't have to be your
you don't have to accept being poor not
in britain not in london
are you kidding me uh the guy who washes
my car
uh drives a range rover you know he
comes over
uh i'm not sure what country's from he's
from an eastern european
nation he comes over he's washing cars
he works seven days a week i don't envy
him you know he works when it's cold
uh whether it's snowing he's out there
washing cars
but he owns a fleet of vehicles he owns
houses in fact i saw the last of my son
was at an auction he was buying
properties
he washes my car yeah he charges me 10
pounds to wash my car and
he does a job that most of us don't have
the time to do
and wouldn't i mean i wouldn't spend an
hour of my time washing my car because
my time is more valuable
but here he is he's a hustler he's
employing people
he's providing employment for people
he's doing well for himself
and so um i don't think you've got any
excuse to be poor in britain
yeah which is why i say it has to do
with your education
it has to do with your environment let's
do your energy you need energy you need
to go out and do something about it
and so i think a lot of people they
watch videos they have lots of
conversations they get a lot of
education but they just don't take a
risk
yeah they're um you know they settle for
the status quo and they settle for
like i said i was raised on welfare in a
single parent home
uh i left school in 1988
and every month since i left school
someone's giving me a paycheck
alongside me being an entrepreneur as
well and so yeah for me
britain is such a great nation yeah of
it's a land of milk and honey land of
great opportunity
anyone with any gumption and some energy
you owe it to yourself to do well i i
couldn't agree more with that
i want to ask you a bit about the
current climate yeah because right now
we're in a very strange time yep we're
in the middle of a pandemic
and there's all kinds of stuff happening
what does that mean for the property
entrepreneur
what does that mean for the property
investor opportunity
right every um every situation is an
opportunity
uh below market value genuine below
market value opportunities
um you know even the rental market um
if people lose their jobs and or lose
their homes or can't afford their
mortgages they're gonna be more likely
to rent
and so the rental market's gonna be
driven up uh they're gonna be more
likely
um if there's single people more likely
to rent a hmo room
et cetera room in a shared house there's
opportunities out there
i mean i've um i've looked at several
online auctions in the last month and
all of them are reporting record sales
i watched one auction in the midlands i
was gonna buy
i was looking at five properties in the
midlands and uh i was astounded as to
how much these properties were going for
because the guide price was
one fifth of what the actual real price
was
i think they changed it just before the
auction and uh i was saying man that's
crazy but people were fighting over
properties yeah and i think that
particular auction i think they sold 200
properties in one day
yeah in the middle of a pandemic in the
middle of a recession in the middle of a
recession so
so obviously there's opportunities out
there so you just got to look for them
yes there are the markets going crazy
right now and i
i i reckon this is always the case
people say what house prices do well
firstly
house prices are different in every area
yeah so every i believe every
every every city has its own economy
yeah i also believe if you want to
predict what's going to happen you need
to look at what's just happened and see
the pan
properties go up they go down they go up
yeah everywhere follows london but
london is no different so you need to
think okay well
when should i buy yeah buy for cash flow
find the right time
but there's always opportunities to make
money in property the season
where more people became millionaires
than ever before was actually just
after world war one and world war ii
yeah i can't believe that
so when there's absolute crisis going on
in a crisis grant cardone says never
waste a good crisis yeah
absolutely you know so while people are
panicking warren buffett when people are
afraid you be greedy when people are
afraid that's the time to get greedy
and the thing that freaks me out a
little bit clement is that
people are losing their jobs right now
yeah the rich are getting richer the
poor are getting poorer
and i think that there's going to be a
lot of people that don't step up and
educate themselves that don't pull the
pants up and start working instead of
just talking
that are going to really suffer over the
next year or two and that's part of
the reason why i do this yeah because i
want to wake people up i want to get
people financially
educated and financially literate um but
i mean what do you think the
fundamentals are that people need to
really do
to to educate themselves to wake up to
like what what what
they've got to be dissatisfied with
their status quo yeah you've got to be
satisfied enough to do something about
it
i think uh being comfortable is the
enemy
of entrepreneurship yeah you know if
you're not worried about your future
if you're not worried about your kids or
your children's children
if you're not right about how things are
gonna work out for you um
you know that's the first step and that
rarity has to translate into an action
so what do people need to do they need
to go decide what they want to do in
life and get educated in that stream you
know
again i was just doing i started off
just doing single let's
move to multi-let's now i'm not going to
start doing developments
it's because as i've got good at one
stage i've kind of moved on and
transitioned
to another stage and so i think that
this
crisis with people losing their job is a
great opportunity for people to become
entrepreneurs
yeah it's a good people it's a good time
for people to say you know what i can't
rely on the job
yeah this is another thing people a lot
you know they'll
they'll sacrifice time in their family
to go and work a job
uh they'll work six seven days a week
they'll do overtime
they will almost sell their soul if i
can use that language for their boss
but the first opportunity the company
gets to make redundant they'll make it
redundant i so work for a merchant bank
it was a good employee wasn't a problem
but
today i don't think there was 250 of us
when i was there
i don't think there's more than five
people still working for that company
from when i was there 20 years ago yeah
so what does that mean well you tend to
move on or you get made redundant
so you can't put your trust in an
employer to make you financially free to
make you wealthy
you've got to take uh you know you've
got to take your own destiny into your
own hands
and you've got to make it work and
you've got to own it you've got to take
ownership
yeah and uh and that's what i learned
from a very young age
i was doing milk rounds uh paper rounds
when i was 10 years old
i was working for pocket money if i
needed something i had to go out and
work for it yeah
it was never given to me on the plate
and so i think people just need to be
dissatisfied yeah they need to want more
than say well listen
i want more out of life i wanna and
there's opportunity all around you
you know i mean the guy who watches your
car
is a millionaire yeah he's a millionaire
car washer
yeah all right he's been in this country
10 15 years
and he's grafting yeah you know no one
gave him anything
you know what did he see that i didn't
see and i think uh
you know and get around people who are
hungry get around hungry people and you
keep talking about environment and it's
i'm so glad that you do that because i'm
i'm a massive believer
that who you surround yourself with is
who you become environment is stronger
than world power
yeah and yes and i think that's really
important people think they just need to
psych himself up and they need to set
goals
if you're doing it alone it's not going
to happen if you're around people by
doing it becomes normal and you just it
just happens
and that's why your crash course was so
impactful for me
because i think it might have been 800
people i'm like man there's 800 property
investors there
and during the coffee breaks and talking
some of this stuff was
evidently obvious to some people and it
was new
to some others you know and you realize
that when you
if you want to be a property investor
and you hang out with property investors
property investing becomes easier yeah
it becomes more normal
yeah but when you're trying to you know
god bless all my friends and my family
but sometimes if i tell them what i'm
thinking of doing
oh are you sure about that oh how's that
going to work out
you know because they because because
some of them themselves are not property
investors
and because they love me care for me
they're careful oh be careful you don't
want to lose your money yeah be careful
that might not work
but when i hang out with property
investors i say oh yeah that's a good
idea you should try this as well have
you thought about this and
here's some companies you might want to
get in touch with these are some
brokers you might want to speak to etc
so you're right your environment
really does make an impact on you yeah
and if you surround yourself with proper
investors who are doing well
it's going to rub off on you it's going
to rub off on you how do you manage your
time i mean you're a pastor you're a
property entrepreneur an investor now
developer
you're a grandad i mean this is a
granddad
thank you very much god but how do you
because i think working hard is
important but also but it's about
working smart managing your time right
taking massive action with the right
kind of action yeah how do you how do
you manage that how do you keep that
spiritual
family work-life balance amongst
everything that you're doing
yeah with difficulty if i be honest um
but you know what i have to look at my
wife my wife probably works twice as
hard as me
and but her life is so organized and
structured
yeah you know she's almost like on the
clock you know to the minute i know
where she's going to be at any
part of her day my life is probably a
bit more up and down i can get a phone
call
that can totally disrupt what i had
planned for the rest of the day yeah
depend on the nature of the phone call
and i think um the older i get the more
i'm realizing that actually as a parent
um what our kids need in particular need
more than toys and gadgets is memories
so again during colvin i took my family
down to europe disney
to paris yeah and so uh once the
ferries had opened uh we drove down to
uh
booked it online drove down to dover
caught the ferry
over to calais euro disney was open the
hotels were open
and it was great because it was empty
and we had a great time doing all the
rides
at least twice sometimes even three
times
because it was only one tenth of the
amount of people that were normally
there
and so you do make time i think what you
do is that you find time in your
schedule and you be intentional about it
so we was meant to go away for a trip
because of lockdown we didn't go too
well the light duster had gone
but you find a way around it well we
can't do that why don't we
go to euro disney and it was great
because we had to drive there
it's about 300 kilometers from calais to
paris
great time in the car great time on the
ferry you know my son who's eight years
old he's looking it's unbelievable he's
blowing his mind he's on the ferry
you know he's in the lounge so we had a
really good time as well looked after
no and so what you do you invest in
memories yeah and that memory
buys you six months you know gives you
that buys you time
it won't last forever you know that
can't be the only memory they have
and so but if you do things like that
several times a year that would be good
uh i tend to put things into it to do
this
if it doesn't go on there to do this
i'll probably forget it and i won't do
it
yeah so there's a visual representation
of some of the things i've got to do
yeah and i assign a priority some of
them have got to be done
so for example uh tomorrow i'm doing a
zoom call
for a group of pastors and uh
and when they told me i was doing i said
i've got lots of time
but i realized looking at my diary
yesterday it's tomorrow morning at nine
o'clock
so um yesterday i'd quickly type up some
stuff get some notes together
begin to think about it after this i'm
going to go home finish off the rest of
my talk
and i'll be ready for it tomorrow yeah
and so i'm not always the best prepared
but i always
end up being prepared but you know what
the people sometimes
i think sometimes you just gotta do more
but do things quicker yes
because you could spend three months
planning that tomorrow or you can spend
three hours doing it
yeah and it would be probably not that
different yes and i also think that
people
often will spend loads of time doing the
stuff that they
like doing but aren't that important
yeah i love what you said about doing
the things that need to get done that's
right
so as a property investor you've got to
pick up the phone
yeah you've got a book the person that
books the most houses is the person that
puts on the most
offers is the person that wins yeah
absolutely rather than
making spreadsheets on right move yeah
absolutely yeah you know
doing doing due diligence on a property
they haven't even booked a viewing on
yet yeah and then they just spent three
hours doing a spreadsheet ring up and
it's sold
yeah absolutely i mean i i buy the fact
i buy
all my properties through auction right
so i'm an auction i love auctions and
and the thing i like about auctions is
the speed of them yes
because i get very frustrated doing
things the traditional way you're
putting an offer the offer gets upset
accepted but there's a chain involved
and any one of those links in the chain
can scaffold a whole deal for everyone
else
and so typically uh buying properties
from auction so i have bought a property
from auction
completed in 28 days refurbished in 28
days
and had it left within 28 days so from
beginning to end from the time i bought
it to the time i refurbs and had tenants
in it and had the property revalued
and pulled up my money was 90 days i've
done it several times
no messing but like no messing around i
i
i love auctions as well as you know i
mean i bought my castle from auckland
you know i like auctions but my
disclaimer to that is
only buy auction if you know what you're
doing because i know a lot of people
watch my youtube videos
get excited and go and go do stuff so
i'll just say get properly trained know
what you're doing
surveys legal packs absolutely view the
house
because you can get burned big time in
auction yeah and i've stormed out of
auctions before
how do you mean i've got so mad at an
auction because everyone's over paying
yeah because some people buy me their
feet i know you say this you don't buy
your feelings you buy your formulas yes
and so i've been in auctions where i'm
like the next property that goes
that high i'm out of it i've stormed out
i just got so angry yeah yeah because
some people are buying things they just
want the project they're not they're not
invested not everyone who buys an
auction is an investor
yeah sometimes they're romantically
involved in the property correct
there's all sorts of emotions going on
and my figures there isn't a column
in my spreadsheet for emotions yes this
doesn't fit onto a mathematical formula
and so i've actually walked out of
auctions for harm done i'm frustrated
because you like me are an emotional
person
right you know you're a big person
you've got a lot of energy but you've
probably i've assumed you've got to
learn
this is formulas absolutely the figures
have to stack up
yes and in fact i would say um you know
i bought a property blind as i mentioned
earlier um and i would say most
definitely should view properties
but what is most important is the number
crunching yeah
it's like what can you do with a
property show me a floor plan yeah
what's the area like what's the
transportation like
uh what can i rent these rooms out for
uh what's gonna be my return investment
roughly how much this you know a new
bathroom a new kitchen
uh fire doors door closes intermittent
strips i kind of know
roughly what that's gonna cost so i can
do that in an
hour on the property and that is more
important than actually looking at it
to me if you can look at it fantastic
and again i've only bought one
one time without looking at it um but
certainly you've got to do your figures
beforehand
and if the figures stack up have you
ever felt like quitting as
the property side of things ever got two
months never never happened never
ever it's all been good never ever it's
all been good in fact i wish i'd bought
more
yeah but i was busy i need to be careful
you know why because sometimes people
say i'll make it all look too rosy make
it too simple
and i'm thinking listen of course of
course there are downsides of course and
there's challenges and it's hard
but it is pretty rosy you know and on
top of that on top of that
complexity is the thief of execution yes
if i make something
if i make something complicated to make
myself look intelligent
what's gonna happen it's gonna stop
people doing it yeah my heart is to see
people win my heart is to see people
succeed so i'm gonna try and keep it
simple stupid yeah
absolutely and and so that people win
there's nothing there's no bad
intentions there
for me i mean i bought like i said i
bought my first property in 1996.
yeah i've seen properties go in london
from 60 000 pounds to 900 000
yeah in 25 years
the same property i've seen properties
double
triple quadruple times 10 in london
in south london so we're not talking
about the richest parts of london
goodness knows what's happening in
mayfair fulham uh wandsworth chelsea and
all those very
you know expensive areas we're talking
about areas like stratford
uh i used to live on romford road which
is a role that leads into stratford
and i was living there for nine years
yeah uh
in the uh in the early 90s prices down
there have
times 10 yeah at least do you think that
that's gonna continue do you think that
in 50 years time though we're gonna say
okay that's a great question because
that's what we used to say 10 20 years
ago oh it can't
carry on like this see the reason i sold
my house that my first one at 112 000
in 1999 i bought it in 96 sold in 99
was that i didn't think it could carry
on like this
yeah the bubble had to burst it's like
we're always saying that
you know a hundred and twelve thousand
pounds yeah
from six so that's what we said so let
me get my money
and buy it right now yes you know what's
funny though as well feminine i always
say you probably heard me say this
look at the best case yeah and wear your
rose colored glasses yeah
but then look at the worst case then
look at the like the case then make a
decision
let's say it doesn't keep doubling let's
say it doesn't is it cash flowing yeah
absolutely
if it's cash flowing positive and it
doesn't double you still make money
best case if it does double and triple
quadruple and it's cash flowing positive
you've become a multi millionaire by
mistake oh you've been an accident
absolutely most of the millionaires i
know became the millionaire by mistakes
they just started they got a couple
deals and then suddenly
things snowballed yeah they became
millionaires listen did you do really
well what
what was it that made you agree to
comment on
winners on a wednesday you know it's
interesting that's we talked about it
briefly beforehand
um so i came to your crash course couple
years ago i was watching your videos
before then and i've been watching your
videos after then i've got a lot of
information
out of your um videos got a lot of
content and it's all free
you know i mean i'm a landlord most
landlords are quite stingy and tight in
my opinion we don't like spending lots
of money on stuff
and so i came to a crash course finally
enjoyed it
um you know i was there i remember being
there thinking to myself this
course must cost you at least 20 30
000 pounds to put on yeah i was like
that don't make sense you gotta start
selling suits i was waiting for the big
sale to come from you
and it only came the first day i
remember really late at the evenings
like the last part of the day
i'm doing these courses the deal finding
extravaganza went
never using your own money yeah whatever
it was back then etc etc
and so i was thoroughly okay with that
i was like i hope you get enough people
to cover your costs
because actually what you're doing
you're spending a lot of money up front
you know in the hope that people are
going to jump on board the training
to recover your that's business that
makes sense i don't promise that at
and so then um you know i know so some
negativity on the internet sometime
afterwards
and uh and some of it was troubling some
of it was oh okay
maybe i didn't see that or that wasn't
my experience and it wasn't my opinion
but i suppose if you listen to enough of
it it could even
you know um mess with your opinion a
little bit
and then i remember there was a thing
with um alan sugar
you know that was bad i was like oh you
know adding sugars this well-known
billionaire maybe you know this doesn't
look good
and i might even posted something on
social media i felt like we messaged you
on
youtube i was like oh sam you got to say
something what happened there bro it
doesn't look very good etc etc
you know when i saw your rebuttal i was
like you know you're right and
the evidence you put up um
adam sugar probably has no idea who you
are he probably doesn't remember meeting
you
before he met a thousand people and i
realized that you know what there's this
bit of a
vendetta going on and i think i was
actually back i feel i was actually part
of a group called the truth about samuel
leeds or something like that
and i just listened to what they said
that's like there's a lot of hatred on
there's a lot of bitterness on there
and it was like over anything i remember
one time you surprised your wife
um i think you took it to paris you said
you was going somewhere else and you
took it to paris and
i thought oh good on them i'm a pastor
any man that takes care of his wife
thumbs up from me and i said ah you got
respect to any man that takes care of
his wife
the negative response i got from saying
that about you
i just i was like really you're being
serious it was just
and it was bitter it was it was it was
his victory on it was it was bad it was
wicked it was it wasn't good
you know and so i thought well you know
i remember i wrote a long post
saying listen guys i didn't come into
this group to be insulted one guy swore
at me
you know told me to f off i was like
whoa
okay you might not want to say it to my
face you know i know there's a lot of
keyboard warriors
around and i kind of responded and said
listen all i did was say the guy you
know
took care of his family you know you
guys just been angry and the vitriol was
so bad i sent them a long pulse and i
left the group
yeah i left the group ironically a
couple of weeks later
i think emilia or one of your staff
members there was a general email out oh
have you ever experienced
have you ever benefited from samuel's
training and i was like you know what
i'm gonna i
had i had benefited but for some reason
because of negativity
i didn't really want to boast about it
right i'm saying it's a weird thing
and i know better than that i'm not you
know and so i said you know what i'm
gonna just say my own experiences and
my experiences and my experiences uh
coming to your training was very helpful
for me
it was free you know you can't go
wrong with free training you know and
the information
i got from your training i implemented
that
and i scaled up my business and it just
gave me the confidence to do what i was
really thinking of doing
and my passive monthly income is
from 2000 to 10 to 12 000 yeah might
even be more i might
these are conservative figures and so uh
yeah so
why wouldn't i want to come and just
celebrate that and say well done and
thank you for that
dude that's really i really appreciate
that
and uh i love what you're about and i'm
just really really grateful that you've
come
your haters inspired me yeah i know
everything happens for a reason and of
course i went through a challenge in
time i did have the press on me
um a lot of negativity and stuff and and
sure you know i've grown through that
yeah but i just it's people like you
that
give me inspiration to keep going yeah
you're doing a great job in
more power to you and i see what you're
doing and i see you've got a heart for
people
and i see you have helped a lot of
people but it's the nature of this
country as well
part of the british psyche is that when
someone's doing well in america they
give you a round of applause
yes in britain they're like you know
they look at you suspiciously well what
have you done wrong and you know people
can't wait to pull you down it's a
it's a part of our culture that i don't
really like it's a very
you know it's almost like anyone who
it's like a crabology
i think in australia called the tall
poppy syndrome you know crabologies this
idea if you put a load of crabs into a
cage
as soon as one crab tries to climb out
the rest of the crabs just pull it down
yeah all right and there's a crabology
mindset in this nation if you do well
you know whether you're a successful
footballer you know earning lots of
money or you're an entrepreneur or
you're doing something you know people
just
you know being successful makes you a
target for people and which is why
you've
mentioned that a lot of successful
people keep quiet i know a lot of
successful people
you would never know they're successful
they keep it quiet there's a guy in my
area
who has 65 houses you would never know
yeah and he won't talk about it he'll
talk to me because he knows i'm you know
you know he helps me he gives me some
advice but he'll never talk about it
because he knows as soon as he says it
you know there's going to be negativity
directed to him because of it that's
right
and so um yeah so that's why um
you know a lot of successful people just
want to keep it quiet
don't let people know etc but you know
um
respect is um given where it's due and
you've been you've been helped to me
it didn't cost me anything again i think
it just cost me a tank of diesel to get
up to birmingham
and the night in the hotel which was
nice anyway i could probably do the
break at the time
yeah and your training was really
helpful for me
yeah and it really helped me what i was
doing and uh it was a blessing you'll
have to come down to your church
absolutely you'd be very welcome all
right bro appreciate you coming out man
god bless you respect
you